today's question comes from Tom in
Pennsylvania he says my wife has always
wanted to go see the Green Bay Packers
at their home field that's like me
saying my wife's always wanted a new
boat oh come on
okay I'm sorry I just I couldn't I got
to keep reading this year they're
playing the Eagles my team oh okay I
know I'm getting there
in November we're on baby step three and
we won't have it completed until March
of 2015 we've been arguing about it for
quite some time I don't think we should
go but she wants to it'll cost $1500
should we go or not you can do whatever
you want to do you're adults you get to
decide but I will tell you my opinion I
love football I'm a season ticket holder
at the University of Tennessee and at
the Titans and I will be at almost every
home game of both of them this year so I
love that but you know what it's not
instead of having an emergency fund to
protect my family
let me help you with this it's a
football game that's a game you they
don't pay you you pay to watch them it's
a game and you don't put that ahead of
your family's financial foundation I'm
really sorry but this is about time to
put on your big-boy pants and your big
girl pants and say that we don't put
games and luxuries ahead of our family's
financial foundation and when you're
walking around without a rainy day fund
well if you got the Packers game you
spent 1,500 bucks you got $2,000 in your
emergency fund instead of 10 like you
should have and the next week you get
laid off the next week you have a car
wreck I'm not against football I'm a
huge football fan and I'm not against
spending $1,500 on a football game when
you have one when you have $1,500 so and
you know honestly Plus seeing the Green
Bay Packers
play at their home field ISM that's
iconic I agree with that you know what I
think they'll be playing next year and I
don't think they'll play the Eagles at
home next year probably year after seems
like they're in the same division if I
remember right and so either way it
doesn't matter I'm not going to this
game one things you have to do if you're
gonna win with money is you have to
learn the ancient word and the ancient
word is an indication of emotional
maturity see one definition of maturity
is learning to delay pleasure adults
devise a plan and follow what children
do what feels good the ancient word is
the word
it's a strange word you've not heard it
in a while no one in America hears this
word and no one likes it it's
politically incorrect you can get thrown
out of entire clubs restaurants and
organizations for seeing this word
people will ostracize you for seeing
this word are you ready it's a nasty
nasty word but it's very seldom heard so
you don't have to worry about hearing it
much no that's the word no well I'm
convinced at the center of the
degradation of the majority of our
culture the disintegration of our
culture before our eyes
is the inability of people to look at
themselves and look at those they love
and say no you could practice it with me
you push the your tongue towards the
roof of your mouth you make a kissing
motion with your lips blow air past and
release your tongue it's a strange
method but you can do is it sounds like
no no no we can't afford it yet no we're
not going out to eat tonight we don't
have any money no I'm gonna vote you out
of office because you don't know how to
say no because all you know how to say
yes you're in a government enabler
you're congressionally codependent so no
we're gonna vote you out of office I
want my money back
if
you got if you went to any other
organization other than your government
and you got the by that you get from
your government if you went into a
restaurant and the and you were charged
$20,000 for a meal like you are for a
toilet seat when you buy one with your
tax dollars to the government you would
say I want my money back
this is ridiculous you know you're
overcharging me no I'm not gonna put up
with this no I've had enough what do you
mean you're gonna make raunchy jokes in
front of me the young lady says at work
no I don't work here anymore because I'm
not gonna put up with you you're scum no
no the employer says no you're not going
to talk like that in our organization
you have to leave No half the things
wrong with our culture is because people
don't have enough frickin backbone to
say no no you can't afford it now all of
society's ills are not camped on your
head
Tom over a football game don't
misunderstand but really that this whole
place can we could all use a little
growing up and we just heard the word no
no I'm tired of you taking my private
property away from me because you are
righteous only with other people's money
your taxation rate is just too high so
I'm going to fire you with my next vote
no I'm not going to put up with this
anymore
no seven-year-old is throwing in a fit
the five year old the four year olds
throwing a fit complete with snot flying
everywhere tears going everywhere laying
in the floor spinning around like
they're breakdancing in the cereal aisle
of the grocery store a complete freaking
meltdown by a toddler or sub toddler you
know what the answer is still no and now
pain is going to follow if you don't get
your little butt up and head towards the
car No
no no is a complete sentence and when I
learned that word it changed my life
financially when I got to the point that
I could actually make a decision myself
and look in the mirror and tell me no
then I was able to say yes because if
you say no a while if you live like no
one else if you pay a price to win later
you get to live and give like no one
else sometimes I've had to look at
people that we're trying to feed hungry
children or drill them well or put up
mosquito nets or buy a car for a single
mom someone was trying to put that money
together and they asked me and I used to
have to say no because I didn't have any
money because all I had said is yes yes
yes yes yes yes I want this yes I'll
have that yes I have worked so hard I
deserve it
oh brother you sound like you're four
years old let me tell you what you
deserve nothing until you've saved up
the money and pay for it
no I know you've heard the word no more
in the last five minutes than you have
and maybe in your entire life or
certainly in the last six or eight
months because if you walk up and down
the street and you have normal
conversations with people in a
politically correct society where
everyone thinks they have nothing but
rights and they have no boundaries and
they spend all their lives walking
around with a chip on their shoulder
looking for an option opportunity to be
offended by someone else we just are not
allowed to say no anymore you can't say
you know I believe differently than you
so
no that's intolerant it's actually
intolerant of my beliefs but it's also
intolerant no no no
practice it with me everyone mmm
this is the Dave Ramsey show
you